c'est un engin qui marche à la voile et
marche très faibles alors j'aime
performances conçu autour des idées base
traverser l'atlantique le plus vite
possible à la voile un bonhomme tout
seul à bord et celui ci est très grand
et puis à battre les grands prix va vite
c'est valable pour toutes les formules
de beaulieu en plus de cela il est très
puissant
il est très homogène très rigide il a
été pour son plan de pont conçu par un
grand spécialiste
eric tabarly la miss paul terre à côté
des sea dogs pour le bateau j'ai tout
fait à paris j'étais étudiant en lettres
rien bonjour j'ai vu passer la lance
dans un jeu leur ont demandé un maître
de conférences à la faculté des lettres
de sydney supporter la boll et australie
et surtout à signaler la voile s'impose
la baie est extraordinaire alice yonnais
de voiliers s'était tout de suite
rappelle mes collègues pratiquer la
voile
il monte les corons ce monde se dit et
jacques rocher management j'ai navigué
comme ça non et qui ont des styles et
puis un jour j'ai voulu aller au large
alors je me suis engagé comme comme
french coup comme cuisinier sur les
voiliers de course croisière les bateaux
la haute mer et j'ai ainsi découvert le
large
quand je suis fatigué c'est là que je
viens peux me reposer je suis bien là si
c'est bien calé même quand le bateau
dans ce qu'on tienne là et coups de mer
des coups de vent ici je suis bien parce
que je parle plus et c'est la collision
avec un cargo et c'est ce qui m'a amené
à ne plus dormir que phare de par
tranches je prends des petites tranches
de sommeil
j'essaie de dormir le moins possible et
nuit pour l'étrange sommeil échelonnées
sur 24 heures d'une demi heure d'une
heure des fois quand c'est le luxe je
m'offre une heure et demie ou même deux
jours le j'arrive le matin à prendre une
tranche de deux bonnes heures de sommeil
sas arfa ce bien est ce que je crois
aussi bien sûr c'est comme tous les
solitaires le risque de passer par
dessus bord et d'avoir personne pour
vous fait chier au passé par saison à
voir le bateau qui s'éloigne csn
c'est la hantise de tous les solitaires
ont fait tout ce cauchemar un jour noté
m
aujourd'hui c'est gagner parce que cette
course
car son but comme genre et quatre en
quatre ans que je me ferai pas je mets
j'ai tout sacrifié sur le plan du
travail sur le plan financier tout et
même sur le plan physique
monsieur oblige avoir froid je me suis
obligea pas dormir des fois où j'ai pas
mangé à mon aise dans certains cas est
tous des fois où j'en ai bavé
physiquement parfois aussi normalement
parce que c'est pas toujours facile de
produire un grand bateau venir
question pour pouvoir continuer à écrire
à son niveau de forme